Even in death, Daenerys Targaryen remains
something of an enigma.
The assassination of Emilia Clarke's icy-haired,
aspiring queen of dragons on HBO's Game of
Thrones was a particularly shocking moment
on a series filled with them.
On the off-chance that you need a refresher,
here's a bit of background: After Daenerys
went mad and torched the capital city of King's
Landing, she finally reached the Iron Throne.
But Daenerys never actually took her place
as the ruler of Westeros.
Before she could even so much as take a seat,
her nephew-slash-lover Jon Snow - played by
Kit Harington - assassinated her for the good
of the realm.
It was a choice that led to his banishment
back to the Night's Watch, bringing Jon's
story full circle.
Following Daenerys' death, her grieving dragon
Drogon wasted no time torching the Iron Throne
to the ground.
Then, the fiery creature scooped up Dany's
body and flew off to an unknown location.
Since the final Game of Thrones episode aired,
many fans have wondered what exactly happened
to Daenerys's body after she was killed.
Where did Drogon take her, and what did he
subsequently do to her?
Now, these mysteries have been somewhat solved,
thanks to the commentary track on the DVD
release of the show's final season.
According to Entertainment Weekly, showrunners
D.B. Weiss and David Benioff have finally
revealed what Drogon did with Daenerys' body
- or, at the very least, one big thing he
didn't do with it.
They've finally debunked the disturbing theory
that Drogon actively ate his mother and master.
You wouldn't do that, would you, Drogon?
In the commentary track, Emilia Clarke notes
that she would have expected Drogon to simply
eat the body of his former master, to which
Benioff replied:
"Drogon's not going to eat you.
He's not a cat.
Did you see how gently he was nudging you?"
So that's good to know: Drogon didn't just
fly away with Daenerys' body and dump it somewhere,
nor did he ravenously devour the remains of
his human "mother."
At the end of the series finale, Samwell Tarly
- played by John Bradley - notes where Drogon
was last seen.
"And Drogon?
Any word?"
"He was last spotted heading east towards
Volan--"
“Farther away, the better.”
He's cut off, but not before revealing a huge
clue: It sounds like Drogon took Dany to Volantis,
which is where Daenerys and her brother Viserys
spent some time following the assassination
of their father during Robert's Rebellion.
Benioff took on another theory about Drogon,
but he provides far less closure here.
We may never know exactly why Drogon destroyed
the Throne after Daenerys died, but Benioff
did hint at his intention in relation to Dany's
own desires, saying,
"If [Dany is] not going to sit on it, no one's
going to sit on it."
When discussing anything even peripherally
related to Daenerys' death - including what
happened to her body afterwards - one must
inevitably speak the name of the man who performed
the deed: Jon Snow.
Daenerys' fiery rampage through the streets
of King's Landing left countless civilians
dead, and it became abundantly clear that
her ruthlessness knew no bounds - a fact that
left Jon with a difficult decision to make.
After Peter Dinklage's Tyrion Lannister quits
his post as Daenerys' Hand of the Queen in
protest, Jon visits him in captivity, and
the two have a serious talk about Jon's next
steps.
Will he turn the other cheek to Dany's shocking
crimes and choose to love her, even though
she's clearly drunk with power?
Or will he kill her, thus ending the chaos
and destruction she brought to Westeros?
We all know Jon ultimately chose the latter,
stabbing Daenerys in the chest as the two
embraced.
And according to the Game of Thrones DVD commentary,
Jon didn't know he was going to do the dreadful
deed until seconds before it happened.
It wasn't his talk with Tyrion that convinced
him to make that grave decision.
It was hearing Dany's warped views on power
and privilege that ultimately made him kill
her.
As Harrington puts it,
"He doesn't know he's going to betray her
until right at the end.
In Jon's head, it's a number of reasons: [Dany]
doesn't factor in anyone else's decisions
and it also means [Dany] is going to kill
my sisters, so it becomes [my] family vs.
her."
Well, Dany may be dead - but at least she
didn't become dragon chow.
And it sounds like Emilia Clarke has her own
theories about what ultimately became of Drogon
and Dany's corpse, judging by what she told
Vanity Fair in November 2019:
"He's just roaming the seas.
Crying.
Arrrf."
"You think he's somewhere happy?
Flying with the corpse in his mouth?"
"Yeah 'cuz it's his momma!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.